pues día un buen día muchas gracias
tenemos un sistema que lamentablemente
todavía no está con la tecnología que se
usa en otros países hemos entrado a la
fase de conteo de actas del acta por
acta entonces demora un tiempo sin
embargo se ha hecho un trabajo a través
de dos empresas encuestadoras en boca de
urna que tiene la aceptación y ya como
usted lo mencionó de las organizaciones
políticas y tienen un margen de error
mínimo el mismo lo mismos que establecen
de que el movimiento al socialismo ha
ganado en primera vuelta no lo cual no
lo mencionó ha sido una sorpresa para
gran parte del país no se esperaba una
victoria en primera vuelta y gran parte
de la población consideraba que podría
haber una segunda vuelta en esta
dirección en este país que además dicho
sea de paso ha sido las elecciones más
largas más tensas y contradictorias de
la historia de nuestro país ahora
políticamente hablando cómo queda luego
de las elecciones el más y además la
imagen del ex presidente morales
bueno el más ha tenido la capacidad de
reconstituirse más se ha reconectado con
los sectores populares eso le ha dado la
posibilidad cabalmente de ganar estas
elecciones creo que al final de cuentas
tuvo la capacidad también emitir los
mensajes que generaron alguna
expectativa y esperanza y tuvo además la
inteligencia de poner un candidato como
luís arce catacora un economista que ha
manejado cabalmente la economía del país
en los últimos años y en la población
asume que ese es el tema más delicado
entre la capacidad para resolver o por
lo menos de enfrentar la dura crisis
económica que se avecina en nuestro país
evo morales tiene tiene ya un liderazgo
prácticamente agotado ya dentro del
movimiento al socialismo hay voces que
pide incluso que el no retorne a la
emergencia o la influencia del nuevo
liderazgo y una discursividad distinta
no más conciliadora una discursividad
por ejemplo a partir del presidente
electo que ha reconocido errores del
pasado algo que no ocurría nunca
en el más simple siéntase extraño esa
falta de autocrítica y eso ha permitido
cabalmente creo que sumen también
algunos votos además además además de
seis pero realmente cruciales de casi el
juicio
el profesor muchísimas gracias por su
tiempo por estar con nosotros acá en
france24 feliz día